-♪ It's the "Tonight Show
Dance Battle," yeah ♪
-All right, here we go.
And now,
this here
is the Dance Move Generator.
We're gonna take turns
hitting this button,
which will randomly select
a never-before-seen dance move.
Whoever's turn it is has to
make up a dance for that move.
And may the best dancer win.
[ Light laughter ]
Blake, since you are the guest,
why don't we go first?
Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
-Okay.
[ Beeping ]
I just hit it?
-Yeah. Whenever you're ready.
[ Beeps ]
[ Laughter ]
-I've sort of been doing that
this whole interview.
-[ Laughing ] No way.
Me too.
All right, here we go.
Trying To Pretend
You Don't Have A Wedgie Dance.
-Okay.
-Roots, can she get a beat?
[ Rhythmic drumming ]
-Okay.
-1, 2.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
[ Audience cheers ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
That's pretty good.
I like that one.
-And I was --
-You had to hide behind me --
You had to hide behind me
to dance.
That's a very interesting move.
-And I was able
to successfully pick my wedgie.
[ Laughter ]
So this was like full...
-Kill two birds, man.
All right.
Almost too real.
Too real. Hashtag.
All right.
Now it's my turn.
Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
I'm gonna put my hand
on the pod.
[ Beeps ]
[ Laughter ]
-Catching the Bouquet.
Okay.
-You've done this lots.
-Exactly. Exactly.
[ Laughter ]
Catching the Bouquet, okay.
-Okay.
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
[ Audience cheers ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Finale plays ]
[ Music ends ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
That's not really fair.
-My -- My wife is so lucky.
[ Laughter ]
-I got to do more groundwork.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah.
-It's all the Shake Weight, man.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
-My mom got me that
for Christmas one year.
-Oh, I got like 10 of them.
-But it wasn't a joke.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's the future of --
-She drives down in the car --
drives down the --
the highway doing that.
-No way.
Please don't do that. Oh.
-I don't know
if you could air that.
-Yeah, I know. Yeah.
We'll have to cut that out.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
Blake, try and top that.
-Okay.
-Start the generator.
[ Beeps ]
[ Laughter ]
-Ballerina
Who Keeps Dropping Marbles.
Okay.
-Wait. Wait.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
-Definitely a new dance.
-Wait. Okay.
-Ballerina
Who Keeps Dropping Marbles.
Roots.
[ Classical music plays ]
Oh.
♪♪
[ Light laughter ]
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
That's beautiful.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Watch out! Hey!
Whoa, whoa! Oh, my God!
She did floor work!
Oh! Dropping mar--
Be careful.
Be careful! My goodness!
Please be careful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Finale plays ]
Good pratfall.
[ Music ends ]
I thought I was real.
Like, oh, my God. All right.
-You did floor work.
-I did floor work.
You get competitive.
I see. I see.
You got competitive.
Let's see if I can top that.
Start the generator.
Let's see what's up.
[ Beeping ]
[ Imitating beeping ]
That's not annoying.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, bang!
[ Beeps ]
[ Laughter ]
Heisman Magician?
Okay?
-I don't know what that means.
-I guess -- what does that mean?
Like a Heisman Trophy?
[ Rhythmic percussion plays ]
-1, 2.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Audience cheers ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Finale plays ]
Sorry.
[ Music ends ]
I'm happy I'm not out of breath
for that one.
But I don't know
how else to do that.
The Heisman -- whatever --
You're gonna --
-You look like you need water.
-You're gonna win this time.
Whatever.
I'm just out of breath.
I'm just totally doughy
right now.
All right, you're clearly
the better dancer.
-"Dancer."
-Why even compete
against each other?
-We can dance, if we want to.
-I mean, we can leave
our friends behind.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause if you can't dance.
-And if they don't dance...
then you're no friend of mine.
-Then you're no friend of mine.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Let's do one more
dance together.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's start
the Dance Move Generator.
[ Beeping ]
-Do it together, right?
-Yeah, here we go.
-1, 2, 3.
[ Beeps ]
[ Laughter ]
-I know that. I can --
-Yeah, yeah.
-I can do that.
-Yeah, it's like --
-Riverdancing Frankenstein.
-Yeah, we always do that, right?
-Yeah, yeah, of course.
That's -- What are we doing?
-Well, 'cause like -- yeah.
Do you want to...
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
-Start from backstage?
-Like this.
[ Celtic music plays ]
-Together? Together or on --
-Each side. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Ready?
[ Music continues ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Audience cheering ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Finale plays ]
-The best in the business --
Blake Lively!
[ Music ends ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That is all for
"Tonight Show Dance Battle."
Our thanks to Blake Lively.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Gabrielle Union!
-[ Singing indistinctly ]
[ Cheers and applause ]